Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Denise RQ
Buongiorno.
Io sono, come avete sentito,
di ritorno dagli Stati Uniti
e fondamentalmente sono stato chiamato
per raccontarvi una storia
che è la mia storia personale,
ma che può diventare
anche la storia di tanti.
Diciamo che - prendiamocela comoda,
cominciamo da un po' di tempo fa,
da quando avevo 13 anni.
Purtroppo, all'età di 13 anni,
la zia, che per me era
una nonna, ha avuto un ictus.
Mia madre, molto coraggiosamente,
ha deciso di portarla a casa.
Questa signora non riusciva più a parlare
e non si riusciva più a muovere.
Tutta la famiglia si è, diciamo così,
coagulata intorno a questo evento
e abbiamo assistito
questa zia per sette anni.
Diciamo che forse, in questi sette anni,
io ho maturato l'idea di fare il medico.
Non lo so, forse l'ho sempre avuto dentro,
forse l'ho maturato in questo periodo.
E quindi ho cominciato, sono entrato
nella Facoltà di Medicina
e ho cominciato a studiare Medicina.
Mentre studiavo Medicina, però,
avevo un po' voglia
di mettere le mani in pasta
per cui ho deciso di fare
il volontario con la Croce Rossa,
una delle tante associazioni
che ti permettono di farlo,
e ho cominciato a girare
con l'ambulanza per la città di Modena
cercando di mettere in pratica
quello che imparavo all'Università.
Poi, finalmente, mi sono laureato.
In questa foto c'è anche Valerio,
un mio carissimo amico,
e anche lui non fa più il medico:
forse c'era qualcosa che non andava,
in quel corso di Medicina.
Però lui ha fatto una scelta
molto più alta della mia.
Bene, decido di studiare
anestesia di rianimazione:
l'ambulanza, l'emergenza
scorreva nelle mie vene
e quindi decido di fare anestesia.
E sicuramente mi rendo conto
che c'è un problema:
il danno cerebrale, fondamentalmente,
pur essendo passati tanti anni,
lasciava ancora tanti pazienti
gravemente menomati
nelle loro funzioni neuronali,
malgrado esistessero delle terapie,
che ovviamente erano state
sviluppate negli anni,
molto efficaci: pensiamo
solo alle 'stroke unit'
dove riaprono i vasi
del cervello che si sono chiusi.
A questo punto mettiamo
in pausa la mia storia,
e facciamo un breve intermezzo di salute.
Che cos'è il nostro problema?
Pensate che ogni sette secondi, nel mondo,
una persona soffre
di danno cerebrale acuto,
da qualche parte nel mondo.
Sono, diciamo così,
la conseguenza dell'ictus,
dell'arresto cardiaco
e del trauma cranico.
È una delle maggiori, diciamo così,
problematiche della medicina d'emergenza,
perché il problema del cervello
è che, nel cervello,
tutto quello che perdi è perso:
non siamo ancora
in grado di farlo rigenerare.
Quindi il tema è, dobbiamo
intervenire il prima possibile
per rallentare quest'inesorabile
perdita di neuroni.
Ed è qui, che un po' zoppichiamo.
Pensate che solo
in Europa e negli Stati Uniti
e anche nel Giappone,
che un po' condivide con noi
i nostri stessi fattori di rischio,
ci sono cinque milioni
di pazienti che ogni anno
soffrono di danno cerebrale acuto.
È la prima causa di disabilità permanente,
ed è la seconda causa
di morte sopra i 50 anni.
Tutti pensano
ad altre malattie e invece no,
purtroppo è il danno cerebrale,
e pensate che ha dei costi spaventosi:
330 miliardi di dollari ogni anno,
questa è una stima dell'Organizzazione
Mondiale della Sanità,
per la cura di questi pazienti.
Gli americani, in questo, sono più bravi,
perché tengono nota
un po' di tutte le spese
che seguono un paziente.
Pensate che solo il primo
ricovero di un paziente
con danno cerebrale in ospedale
in media costa 15.000 $,
e se questo paziente sopravvive
ogni anno si pensa che siano,
si stima che siano 20.000 $
fra esami, cure, ma anche
mancata capacità di lavoro
perché ci sono persone giovani,
che magari hanno 60 anni,
che stanno ancora lavorando
e che non possono più lavorare.
E ci sono degli altri studi
che dicono che,
se tu hai una persona
colpita da danno cerebrale,
o comunque disabile in casa,
uno dei suoi familiari
deve perdere il lavoro
o ridurre significativamente il suo lavoro
per prendersi cura di questo paziente.
Quindi capite che è un problema
di dimensioni globali,
e che mette a repentaglio la stessa
sopravvivenza dei sistemi sanitari.
Bene, chiudiamo questa piccola
parentesi e torniamo alla storia.
È il 2012, io mi sto
finendo di specializzare,
anzi mi sono specializzato
e tac, dream job:
assegno di ricerca con l'Università,
lavoro in rianimazione.
Sistemato perfettamente.
Dovevo cominciare
a lavorare il 21 di maggio:
il 20 maggio tira il terremoto.
Quindi, probabilmente il mondo
non è finito nel 2012,
ma sicuramente per me è cambiato.
Poi, non pago, tira anche il 29,
con dei danni grossissimi,
soprattutto nella parte nord
della provincia di Modena
che è quella dove appunto c'è Mirandola:
io ero allora al Policlinico di Modena.
Ovviamente anche Modena
ne è stata colpita,
anche il Policlinico ha affrontato
delle ristrutturazioni interne
e la mia prospettiva di lavoro
è diventata, improvvisamente,
meno sicura.
E quindi, a questo punto,
in un momento di maggiore incertezza
mi sono focalizzato su delle idee nuove.
In fondo io ero il cliente
di me stesso, no?
Ero un medico, avevo avuto
esperienze in ambulanza,
e mi ero chiesto, in ambulanza:
ma perché non esiste niente
con cui poter aiutare
questi pazienti col danno cerebrale
nel tragitto dall'ambulanza all'ospedale?
E quindi, diciamo così, comincio
a ragionare su quest'idea
che è quella che poi mi ha portato
all'idea della mia startup.
E quindi questa è un po' la storia, no?
Quindi, io ero un medico,
e cercavo una soluzione a questo problema,
lavoravo con questo tipo di pazienti.
A questo punto penso,
ma perché non portare una strategia nota
di protezione cerebrale, cioè l'ipotermia,
cioè ridurre la temperatura del corpo
per rallentare la morte
dei neuroni fuori dall'ospedale?
Si faceva già in ospedale,
io non l'ho inventata,
non l'ho scoperta io,
non voglio meriti che non ho.
Dico, proviamo a portarla
fuori dall'ospedale.
E quindi comincio a lavorare
su questa soluzione
e deposito una domanda di brevetto ,
perché un amico di mio padre
che faceva il professore universitario
mi ha detto, ma se sei proprio
convinto di quest'idea,
perché non depositi
una domanda di brevetto?
Io ho detto, perché no?
E quindi l'ho fatto.
Nel mentre, avevo ancora il mio impiego,
il mio assegno all'Università
e cercavo dei fondi per le mie ricerche,
ricerche che stavo conducendo con
dei brillantissimi giovani ricercatori,
neuroscienziati dell'Università di Modena.
Nel cercare questi fondi incontro
quello che io definisco
un misterioso estraneo
cioè un signore
da cui io andavo per chiedere
appunto dei fondi per la ricerca,
che mi dice: ma guarda che la tua idea,
in realtà al di là della ricerca,
quella del brevetto,
potrebbe avere uno sfruttamento economico.
Ti andrebbe di presentarla
a un fondo di investimento?
Io non sapevo neanche che cosa fosse,
un fondo però dico, di nuovo,
perché non presentarla,
tanto che male può fare?
Mi dice guarda, sarà difficilissimo.
Bene, presento.
Due mesi dopo, silenzio per due mesi,
io preoccupatissimo,
quasi me ne ero dimenticato,
- tac, una telefonata,
[mi si] dice, dottor Giuliani,
la sua idea ci è piaciuta,
vuole venircela a presentare?
E io l'ho presentata.
Vado da questo fondo di investimento,
mi dicono sì, la sua idea
è molto interessante:
però lei è da solo,
gli one man show non funzionano,
quindi le offriamo una possibilità,
un corso che chiamano di accelerazione
dove le faremo conoscere
delle persone che hanno
delle competenze diverse dalle sue,
e che la aiuteranno a costruire,
intorno alla sua idea,
un progetto fattibile.
E quindi inizio questo
programma di accelerazione.
Intanto avevo trovato
un altro lavoro in ospedale,
ero andato a lavorare a Reggio,
che ha un bellissimo ospedale.
Però il programma di accelerazione
alla fine era molto intensivo,
e io faccio una scelta, dico:
nella vita bisogna non avere rimpianti.
E quindi dico, se devo fare questa cosa,
questo progetto imprenditoriale,
facciamolo dedicandoci al 100%.
Quindi decido di lasciare il mio lavoro
per dedicarmi al mio programma,
e fondo Neuron Guard,
che è la startup mia
e della mia socia, Mary,
che è appunto il prossimo tassello
perché durante questo programma
di accelerazione incontro tante persone
che mi aiutano tutte,
ed in particolare Mary.
Mary è laureata in Economia,
ha fatto un Master alla Bocconi
in Imprenditorialità
e strategia aziendale,
ha gestito dei centri di riabilitazione,
quindi un po' questo tema
del danno cerebrale,
- lei vedeva più il dopo,
e poi sicuramente ha delle competenze
economiche che io non ho.
E con Mary saltiamo nel vuoto,
decidiamo di fondare la nostra startup.
L'idea è quella di un collare refrigerante
che, raffreddando il collo,
raffredda il sangue che va al cervello
e quindi raffredda il cervello.
E il nostro messaggio chiave
è quello del trattamento precoce
sul luogo dell'evento,
perché prima agiamo,
prima possiamo limitare i danni cerebrali.
Da lì in poi, con l'aiuto
di un incubatore modenese
che si chiama Democenter,
abbiamo trovato una sede in un container
lasciato lì dal terremoto a Mirandola,
quindi il terremoto torna
dentro anche non volendolo.
E quella è la nostra sede,
dipinta di verde,
perché era un laboratorio analisi
quando l'ospedale
aveva avuto dei problemi.
Siamo anche stati negli Stati Uniti,
subito dopo il programma
di accelerazione, e adesso.
Però io quello che dico
è che la mia Silicon Valley è Modena,
nel senso che io a Modena ho trovato
un tessuto di imprenditori, di istituzioni
che mi ha supportato e mi ha dato
quello che forse non avrei
trovato da altre parti.
Cioè una disponibilità
e una prontezza ad agire
che mi hanno permesso, da medico,
di fare questo salto
verso l'imprenditoria.
E concludo con quello che è ormai
il motto di Neuron Guard:
"Time is Brain. Freeze it!".
(Applausi)